let's speak to people in the audience
last week's calls were fascinating some
of the better calls we've had
let's see if we can keep the streak
going we take calls via discord you can
find our discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord it's free completely and
totally free
let's start today
with jude from canada jude welcome
what's going on
hey david um i was just wondering uh
what you thought about canada's role in
the
ukraine uh russia conflict and then i
was also wondering if you think canada
will be soon to follow with the u.s
recession so my understanding on in
terms of canada's involvement is
canada has provided
some training primarily and maybe some
arms to ukrainians and is it through
poland that they've done it i apologize
if i don't have all the facts in front
of me
yeah i believe that's it yeah i mean i
don't find anything particularly
shocking
nor remarkable in the positive or
negative i mean it seems that the vast
majority of canadians
similarly interpret this as an
aggression act an invasion act by russia
they are
sympathetic to the ukrainian cause and i
mean i don't is there something more
specific you wanted me to react to it
seems sort of like a normal response i
guess i would say
no that would that would be that would
be it i was more wondering about the
recession question i have no idea i mean
again i don't it's it really doesn't
seem to me that the us is in a recession
i know that there's this technical
when there's two consecutive quarters of
gdp
shrinkage
we are in a recession but the last gdp
reduction from last quarter was so small
and when you look at the details it's a
result of decreased government spending
decreased inventories partially from
people buying so much stuff it's just
hard to look at that and being at nearly
full employment and the stock market
seemingly on the up and up at least over
the last half month or so and say this
is clearly a recession so never mind is
canada heading to a recession i don't
even know that the us is in one
okay interesting thank you
all right jude from canada thank you so
much for the call i appreciate it